placer mon dossier qu'ovide il ya un peu
la dose le cardiologue tout ça c'est les
prises de sang 400 euros de prison quand
même j'ai attrapé le coc vide le 19 mars
simplement d'un long travail et c'était
une pièce fermée avait une collègue et
tous ces pas et sait se trouvait qu'elle
avait le collier des quatre jours après
j'ai développé les premiers symptômes
fait six mois maintenant et depuis je
fais toujours pas guéri alors il ya eu
du mieux
il y aussi beaucoup de rechuter beaucoup
de points négatifs les symptômes du cog
hill long que moi j'ai c'est pas les
mêmes que ceux que j'avais au début
au début c'était tout est fatigué mal de
tête et maintenant c'est surtout
détresse respiratoire donc essoufflement
fortes douleurs à la poitrine
comme si en fait j'avais une pierre
chaude qui gonflait et kim écrasée de
plus en plus pour moi le plus dur je
pensais de plus pouvoir être active
j'ai des malaises après l'effort
maintenant presque systématiquement et
même si des fois ça s'améliore ça c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment difficile à 27
ans au pouvoir est traqué là c'est le
graphique de l'épreuve d'effort qui
montrent pourquoi j'ai une d autonomie
donc ça c'est la fréquence cardiaque
donc on voit qu'à monte à l'effort ce
qui est normal et là ma tension
artérielle on voit qu'elle est plate
ça monte pas mon voisin que là ya une
dérégulation parce que la tension
artérielle n'est pas monté à l'effort
[Musique]
je ne suis jamais allé à l'hôpital
avants locaux vides comme ça j'avais une
opération une fois mais deux fois deux
fautes nous votre afro cardio l'irm
scanner scintigraphie tu va repasser
encore un scanner on s'arrête pas et
j'ai dû aller ou peut-être une quinzaine
de fois l'hôpital en six mois quoi avant
ben cherche une nutritionniste de
formation donc je mangeais plutôt bien
en fait j'adore cuisiner je suis sportif
je ne fume pas je ne bois pas j'étais
vraiment en forme
j'étais très quelqu'un de très joyeux
vraiment il était bien et bah maintenant
je suis toujours qu'on quelqu'un
d'optimiste mais avec un un bel handicap
en plus du messin thomas actuellement je
ne peux plus toute seule j'ai trop de
fatigue j'ai trop de problèmes la
cardiaques et pulmonaires qui fait que
je peux plus tout seul du coup à 27 ans
je retrouve du chez mes parents j'ai
totalement changé mon rythme de vie et
j'espère pouvoir reprendre un rythme de
vie normal donc je veux rebondir je suis
motivé je suis optimiste je vais
rebondir mais c'est pas facile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on ne sait pas on ne peut pas prédire
qui va garder des symptômes persistants
pendant deux trois ou quatre mois
comprendre ce qui se passe est une chose
proposer des solutions c'est ce qu'on a
fait à nos patients c'est à dire en
fonction des symptômes donc ces
plaignants on aura essayé de leur
proposer une prise en charge
et puis on essaie de voir deux mois plus
tard est ce que la piste dans lesquels
on s'est engagé avec les patients elle
est plutôt bénéfique où elle est sans
efficacité
il ya des gens qui ont perdu énormément
de masse musculaire
donc inévitablement dès qu'ils ont
besoin de faire un exercice et bien ils
sont fatigués parce qu'ils n'ont pas
récupéré ni le moteur
cardio-respiratoire ni leur moteur
musculaire
le deuxième grand profil de patience et
des gens qui conservent à syndrome
anxieux tout le monde n'a pas la même
capacité à faire face à ce stress inédit
il ya des gens qui gardent un syndrome
anxieux pour certains ils l'ont vécu
comme un stress post traumatique
et puis il ya le troisième profil des
gens qui ont vraiment des perturbations
dont on pense qu'elles sont liées
vraiment à l'infection virale qui reste
c'est à dire les anneaux semi les
agaléens perte du goût perte de l'odorat
des gens qui ont toujours des problèmes
respiratoires avec en particulier ce
qu'on appelle un syndrome
d'hyperventilation c'est à dire une
respiration superficielle qui n'est pas
efficace et dont on sait pas ce que
c'est une maladie qu'on connaît depuis
longtemps qu'elle provoque une partie
des symptômes danses pleines dents se
plaignent les gens il faut les aider à
ce que cette récupération qui est très
très longue soit un petit peu accéléré
par une prise en charge adaptée un
reconnaît leurs symptômes
on essaie de leur dire comment ça
fonctionne pourquoi ils ont ces
symptômes là et on essaie de leur
proposer une solution et on réévalue
cette solution à deux mois